but you can't judge your current period  based on who you used to be you have to  judge it on who you are now and then  that period will pass and you will be  able to take on some more risk at times  i mean that's just the way things go  there are seasons to life and maybe you  used to be freer and you could do these  things a little bit easier but that  doesn't mean that was better it just  means you're in a different period of  your life now  and so i'm not trying to like  get underwater you know five days a week  because it's unrealistic it won't happen  if i do that i will never work and you  know that's not good so like i had to  figure out a way to make it work and  it's and it's constant constant  communication to continue to make it  work